[Music]
just close your eyes and imagine you're
flying
[Music]
can we have a swing in our next home
we'll find one with trees around it oh
yes
apple trees
hey
i've flown enough i think should we go
back
yes
[Music]
hello
oh
hello
and welcome
you're new here yes
well actually we're a bit lost
and where are you going
not to roam i would have seen no we're
looking for an island
it has two deep and there's a bird and a
small lake and flowers it's probably an
island with two large mountains we were
told you could help us find it
not from memory
but i have an old map of the
mediterranean sea somewhere
do you want to have a look
yes thank you that'll be perfect good
people
what's going on we're looking for a boy
and a girl the girl has killed several
soldiers she's armed and dangerous by
order of camp victoriaville we're
searching this cat i know a guilty look
when i see one
but
whatever you've done
i won't give up a child
come with me
[Music]
[Music]
take your house
[Music]
yes
i'm dizzy
your hand
you're bleeding again
[Music]
we must leave
yes
we have to keep
moving
where are we looks like
a quarry
we're going in there it's dark
i don't
know if there's another way
where are they
don't let's push inside we must not stay
in the open
stop
there are people
i hear nothing how do you know i
i feel them
i think it's the rat
i can try to feel better
you're sure about this
yes don't worry
fine
careful
yes
i see them
they're here soldiers
hold on
how
the rats
they can feel people's blood now i can
do
it's like a noise
like an echo so where are they close
coming i can do it again if you want got
it let's go careful
they're trapped in here
they can't go back
where are the workers
this one isn't abandoned is it
i don't stop your bloody superstitions
it's the captain you should be afraid of
the girl pissed him off worse than a
thousand englishman
[Music]
so
[Music]
stay
the wall doesn't use women or children
they're here too
how do we get out of here
we need to get out
[Music]
oh no they'll find us we have to reach
that building it is a church
don't know
but we're too exposed we'll try in there
may be safer
search the area get that witch
they won't give up
i had butchers did you kill a lot in the
red city
oh
[Music]
we can
we can make it
yes then you'll rest
clear
be careful
you're too tired
don't
worry
nice sound
what's happening
[Music]
i'm fine
who did this
first
remember
the council wants this land cleaned of
his scar
this girl killed your brothers
our execution will take place here
what's making that noise
it's them
they did this
i better have a look over there
[Music]
ah
no
it's bleeding a
lot they're coming
i can't you have to handle it yourself
are you sure
do it
quick
are you tired
[Music]
no
[Music]
we have to get out of here